you can watch any program you see here
online at booktv.org
next on book tv marin katusa argues that
vladimir putin's dream is to restore
russia's past glory by dominating the
world's energy supply
mister katusa says that if putin
achieves this goal the u.s and other g7
countries will find themselves playing
second fiddle economically to countries
like russia brazil india and china this
is about an hour and ten minutes
i'm very pleased to introduce our
speaker marin katusa who is the chief
energy investment strategist at kcu
research
his
book is apparently
breaking records and cracking all kinds
of best-seller lists in numerous
categories international affairs public
policy etc so
you heard it here my friends
he's an accomplished investment analyst
he has served as chief investment
strategist at casey research since 2007.
his funds are among the top performing
in the resource sector over the last
five years in canada he's a regular
contributor to the business news network
and has been interviewed by global media
outlets such as cnbc cbc bloomberg and
forbes
marin has traveled to
numerous
numerous
conflicted and challenging areas
including russia iraq ukraine kuwait
mongolia kosovo and colombia among other
resource-rich destinations
he's a former mathematics professor
and he's
[Music]
hello
okay
how are we doing
not good well there we are we back okay
um so i think that happened because of
my my own personal history with
mathematics but we'll just gloss right
over that anyway so marin is a former
mathematics professor and he's used his
advanced mathematical skills to create a
diagnostic resource market tool that
analyzes and compares hundreds of
investment variables over the years he's
been involved in raising over a billion
canadian dollars in capital for early
stage and producing resource companies
marin speaks fluent serbian and croatian
and is conversant in russian
and he's a graduate at the university of
uh british columbia and lives now in
vancouver
so um marin is going to speak for about
30 minutes then we'll have our
traditional q a and then there'll be an
opportunity um to get signed books at
the end so with that welcome marin
[Applause]
what happened was through the
investments traveled to over 100
countries um canada's third largest
producing copper mine and one of the
founding directors at one point was the
largest
investor and shareholder and then as i
really got into the internationalization
of investing in emerging energy markets
i was the largest investor and the lead
finance here in the first two rounds of
what is today's europe's most successful
shale
gas company in the uk called quadrilla
so my funds have outperformed the index
by over 600 percent myself and doug
casey are larger shareholders of the
fund so how did this all happen i've
been talking about this colder war for
about a decade now and i've been going
to places to invest to find solutions
for countries such as germany or the uk
who've been increasing their energy
dependence on germa on russia for
example germany over the last decades
increased its dependency on russian oil
by 52 something the media doesn't talk
about but about a little over two and a
half years ago i had a heart attack
and i ended up with a quadruple bypass
so
all of the
hectic traveling of over 300 days a year
over 10 years caught up with me and i
ended up writing the book called the
colder war we have some great videos on
our website which we really explain what
the colder war is all about so please
visit the website the coldreward.com
after this so let's just jump into this
i got 30 minutes
the end of the lost decade
the west in our media not just in the
north america but in western europe has
really demonized vladimir putin such
that they make him like the darth vader
of the world a they compare him to
joseph stalin for example david cameron
the prime minister of
britain just came out this past weekend
compared putin's russia to the nazis you
know there's a lot of misinformation out
there
but it is clear that vladimir putin has
already made his strategic moves
but not with the sword but with world's
energy supplies now how did this all
happen
after the fall of the ussr
russia was in shambles the soviet empire
was truly
in crumble
it's fair to say that russia was an
economic bastard basket case
overnight russia went from over 70 years
of communism
to capitalism and most in russia had no
concept of what capitalism really was
they had no idea what to do
the morale in russia was very low from
the strong soviet empire to now begging
the west for money
so what happened here
unfortunately it got worse for the
russians before it got better for
example in 1994
they lost the invasion the first
war in chechnya where the chechen rebels
sent the russian army back home
so after the fall of soviet union putin
who was in east germany at the time
went back to st petersburg
and he became an advisor on
international affairs to the mayor of
saint petersburg
this is where putin really created his
inner network who were to travel with
him to moscow and spend the next 20
years of his life together i nicknamed
the st petersburg boys and these are
very important members one of them such
as dimitri medvedev he first started
as just an assistant to putin in st
petersburg later on became prime
minister then president-elect prime
minister and also ran gasprom which is
the world's largest gas producer for
some time
so in 1996 when putin moved to moscow he
eventually brought over those saint
petersburg boys who would eventually
rule over the russian economic sector
the energy sector the transportation
sector and even the media and the
political sector these guys are very
important such as igor sechen who's been
with putin for over 20 years he runs
rosneft and he's the deputy prime
minister there's very important studies
of what putin's done here to gain his
power
so
let's go look into this by 1998 putin
was the head of the fsb that's the old
kgb that we know of in the west and he
was very
unknown on the international stage
within 12 months putin was given the nod
to be the sixth prime minister in less
than eight years
and is president of the time as boris
yeltsin no one expected anything of
vladimir putin is a relatively unknown
but yeltsin took a liking to him and
more importantly the oligarchs at the
time approved of him
so where did that go from well
putin understood that there were five
prime ministers before him that
accomplished nothing and putin knew that
he had to do something drastic something
very competitive and most importantly
something that will get him the national
stage
his first move had to be a big one and
he had to succeed
by late september of 1999 putin figured
out what that move was
and it was to go to war with chechnya
but this time he needed to deliver a
quick and decisive victory to the
russian people and that's exactly what
he did putin's plan was scorched earth
policy the russian army advanced
slowly and in force using both artillery
and air power against the chechnya's
defenses the result over three hundred
thousand of the eight hundred thousand
citizens of chechnya fled to
fled from the russian advances and fled
outside of chechnya
putin back then knew the importance of
controlling the media
and during that second war chechnya no
journalists or media were allowed in the
war zone something important to
understand for later aspects
putin delivered to russia what the
people really wanted at the time a quick
victory and people took notice
then just before midnight on december
31st 1999 yeltsin unexpectedly resigned
he appointed putin the president
and everyone was like shocked
and the national stage they were all
asking questions who was this man in
less than 18 months putin went from the
head of the old
kgb the fsb
to
prime minister to president never done
before in the history of russia
so however most leaders who achieved
such an advanced
acceleration in their career would be
pretty happy with that
maybe write a book
do speeches get paid for it that's not
putin this was just the beginning of his
plan
and now putin had his eyes on the
oligarchs which he needed to consolidate
the power if he was to execute his plan
we talk in great detail in the book the
colder war of how putin humbled the
oligarchs
but i really want to focus on one the
most important one
after 70 years of communism almost all
the russians were struggling to adopt
the principles of the free market
society
there's an old joke in the communist
russia we pretend to work they pretend
to pay us
however not all were totally clueless
about capitalism
enter the individuals who would
eventually become the oligarchs they
were young they were smart they were
aggressive
they took risks they violated russian
laws
most were actually jewish and i'll point
out why this is important in a later
section
but they were very ruthless
unfortunately they were not as
ruthless as putin they would find out
later
putin correctly recognized that the
power of the oligarchs
had not just of the russian
economic aspects but the oligarchs
controlled
the political aspects within russia
and that's what putin really set out to
change
for the sake of time i'll focus on the
most powerful and wealthiest one mikhail
kordorowski we already know of him in
the west because he spent 10 years in
the russian prison
what's interesting about his past
is cordovsky was actually the communist
youth leader of russia
however because he saw what was going on
he saw that the russian empire was
crumbling he wrote a treatise
called the man with the ruble and he was
really studying the free market system
he had a large import business that was
actually the largest bootlegger of
alcohol in russia and also the largest
bootlegger of
hardware and software in russia at the
time and they violated many many of the
russian laws at the time
so it's interesting
here's a guy that was the youth leader
of the communist party
switched over did a 180 created a large
import company and took advantage of the
collapse of the ussr
but what really set him apart from the
other
smart young guys he created a bank
called minitep
which was the vehicle that eventually
took over the russian oil sector
by late late 1989 bank mediatek
controlled
by kodorowski made hundreds of millions
of dollars from diverted state funds of
russia
when yeltsin took over as president
cordovsky was one of his key strategic
advisors on the economic front for
finances cordova kordorowski profited
hundreds of millions of dollars from the
voucher debacle now what was this
voucher tobacco the russian sector had
major companies and what they really
wanted to do was make sure every
individual within russia had an equal
share
of the company so there's 140 million
citizens in russia each person would get
a representative share of a company and
the state would own the largest
controlling block unfortunately remember
70 years of communism people didn't know
what to do with these shares and there
was no true stock market there wasn't
the new york stock exchange or the
toronto stock exchange people didn't
know what to do with these vouchers well
kordorovsky's bank ninatep created a
market for these and they literally
bought these on pennies on the dollar
from people that didn't understand what
was going on
so they created a market for it and he
controlled a lot of these companies
through his bank meet attempt but this
was just the beginning of what
kordorovsky entered the billionaires
club and after 1993 through the loan for
shares deal
that was the key deal
that's how bank meniteb contr took
control of the russian oil sector
through yucos in 1993 yukos was created
by the consolidation of dozens of
russian oil and gas companies
hoping to share the wealth with the
russian people
it was eventually the largest producer
of oil in russia
korowski took control of this via two
methods
by 1994
yeltsin needed a lot of money his his
approval ratings were less than five
percent
and he needed 159 million dollars just
to meet the week's budget so what did
they do they created a plan where the
government would put up the shares of
yukos
for the money unfortunately the
collateral the assets of the company
were worth 25 to 50 times what the
principal amount bank meditate put up
they literally took control of 43
percent of bank mean of yukos
for about five cents on the dollar
within a week
yeltsin needed another 150 million
dollars who did he look forward to he
went to korovsky this time the russians
got a better deal they paid they sold it
for 15 cents on the dollar so
essentially
the whole bill of what kordorovsky
bought this for he
paid it all back within three months
from the cash flow from yukos it was
literally a brilliant move for him a
disaster move for the russian state
so what what happened here
this perspective really changed putin's
concept here
and how these oligarchs were literally
picking up state key assets for pennies
on the dollar
cordovsky no doubt was a brilliant
businessman he brought north american
technology he brought north american
know-how and equipment most importantly
he brought north american
people to improve the production from
the yukos for example we all talk about
fracking here in north america before
george mitchell made it famous
in the permian
it was actually happening in russia
believe it or not
so the canadians were fracking away at
yuko's assets
but yet within just a few short years of
taking control of yukos korowski became
the 16th richest man in the world with a
net worth of over 16 billion dollars
this is a prime example how the
oligarchs in russia controlled all
aspects of the russian economy and media
that is however until putin showed up on
december 31st 1999
initially putin had the support of most
of the very powerful oligarchs
that all changed after the first
election in early 2000
putin set his eyes on the oligarchs he
recognized that if he needed to move his
agenda forward he needed to get rid of
the oligarchs so he proposed the deal to
the oligarchs
if you don't meddle in my politics and
russian politics i'll let you keep the
money that you stole from the russian
people it's a fair deal in putin's eyes
now go back to the most powerful eye uh
oligarchy
he refused and he didn't just refuse the
deal he actually challenged putin and
funded
the political opponents to putin but
also challenged them publicly if you
understand the slavic mentality and the
way russia business is done in russia
you see the exxon deal with rosneft
who's in the middle overseeing it putin
the one big thing in russian business is
if if the russian president is seen
signing the deal
the bill will be passed
so
cordovsky took on putin and
unfortunately lost but he did it with a
double edged sword approach
the the final straw that really ruined
kordovsky was he tried to sell yukos in
a bidding war between chevron and exxon
both rockefeller spinout companies from
standard oil
ironically if korovsky succeeded in
selling yukos
he would become the largest shareholder
of either exxon
or chevron whichever one succeeded in it
however
the president of exxon didn't quite like
kororowski too well he phoned up putin
and said look do you approve this and
putin said no we don't
and you uh korowski tried to do the deal
without getting putin's approval you
don't do that on major national
interests in russia in putin's russia
so what happened well using russian law
they put korowski in prison for tax
evasion
and most importantly they seized the
assets of yukos
they also
froze all the bank accounts
then they went using russian law
there's an old saying in russian law
that it can be interpreted whichever way
the government wants it to be
interpreted and they demanded tens of
billions of dollars in penalties and tax
evasion but because they froze the
accounts of the company there was no way
that yukos could pay
that penalty
and the russian state took over those
assets now what happened there well
essentially they went up for auction
was it a fair bid process did exxon or
chevron anyone else get to bid on it no
a shell company that was
funded by less than 350 u.s dollars
bid for these assets
had no money in the bank account but
were awarded the assets of yukos within
a week they merged with rosneft and the
shell company and in the book we get
into great details who actually controls
the shell company i think you can all
figure out who it was and interestingly
enough it passed with no problems so
what about
the individuals who agreed to putin's
plan
roman abramovich the owner of the
football club chelsea
his net worth actually increased
but he had to agree to putin's plan
the wealthiest oligarch in russia today
uzmanov is a uzbekist he's actually born
in uzbek uh he's an
of uzbek
ethnic he's not even
born in russia
and he's a muslim so to putin he's very
pragmatic he doesn't matter what
religion you are or where you're born if
you play with putin's rules he'll let
you keep what you have
so then we get into the great game in
the 20th century
let's first take back a look at the 19th
century there were 321 global conflicts
in the 19th century 73 of those britain
was involved in
and 50 france britain was the world
superpower at the time 52 of those
major global conflicts were just in
europe only in the 20th century
53 major global
conflicts worldwide
of those 53 the ussr and russia were
involved in 38 of them
usa was involved in 19 of the 53.
now we see that there's a transition the
more wars you're involved in
the less well you do in the next
generation
in the 21st century
there's there's been so far nine major
global conflicts china's been involved
in zero of them
russia has been involved in one
usa anyone can make a guess
all nine
now oil and 20 centuries became the
underpinning of the financial sector you
control the oil you control power how
did this all start petroleum by no means
is a modern discovery historically it
was gathered from natural oil seeps used
in babylon in its walls and
like what you would think it is that was
babylon was a great victim of the first
desert storm
oil was drilled in china about 400 bc
but our modern petroleum era actually
began in the russian empire in 1846 now
what do i mean by modern petroleum era
that's because the first modern well
drilled by mechanical equipment actually
occurred in the russian empire the first
oil valve drilled in the u.s occurred 13
years later titusville pennsylvania by
edwin drake
initially oil was used as a lubricant or
to produce kerosene for heating and
lighting
but everything changed in 1876 with the
invention of the internal combustion
engine
so baku at the time
which was at this time in the russian
empire today azerbaijan
was the world's largest producer of oil
in the world between 1875 and 1895 the
baku oil fields experienced a 200-fold
increase in oil production not a 200
percent increase
200 times increase in oil production
the population of baku at the time was
growing faster than london
new york and paris combined
unfortunately later on for the russians
and the ukrainians oil wasn't the only
thing that came out of the baku joseph
stalin learned the power of oil
and created his ideas while he was born
and raised in his early adulthood years
in baku
the nobel family actually took notice of
the bakku oil fields very early as did
the rothschilds
both along with many other foreigners
invested significant amount of capital
to increase the oil production by 200
fold
interesting facts about the baku oil
sector the nobels we all know them for
dynamite the nobel peace prize yet they
were the inventors of the modern day oil
pipeline that was first put in place in
the baku oil fields also the oil tanker
that was invented by the nobels
also first put into place in the baku
oil fields so by the 1900s the russian
empire produced about 15 percent of the
world's oil
but things started to change in the us
by this time
in 1899
a croatian immigrant named anton lucic
better known in north america as andy
lucas planned on drilling an oil well in
texas
that eventually became the world famous
well called spindle top
it was a gusher what do i mean by a
gusher it produced over a hundred
thousand barrels of oil a day and that
set off a boom by 1910 us became the
world's largest oil producer
oil war and peace they're very directly
linked after world war one it was clear
to winston churchill remember he was the
general admiral of the navy then he
became the prime minister
and he realized that great britain
needed to modernize its navy to compete
with the modernization of the german
military
but to do so you needed to secure a
long-term supply of oil that britain
would control
great britain secured the supply from
iran
and this was critical advantage
that the allies had in world war ii
oil was one of the main reasons hitler
attacked russia in the winter
and we know how that ended
but let's note russia worked with the us
and uk to defeat the nazis something
today
our media forgets
now i'm not here to glorify putin i'm
here just to lay all the facts are so
you can make the decisions for yourself
but history took a dramatic change
during the bretton woods conference in
july of 1944.
two critical outcomes
occurred out of this conference first
the 44 allied governments agreed to
maintain a fixed currency versus the u.s
dollar
interestingly enough russia was never
invited to this meeting
and they never agreed to this
but the 44 allied nations who agreed
each country pledged
to buy and sell the u.s dollar to keep
the currency within one percent of the
agreed upon exchange rate
and if everyone agreed to that the u.s
government
assured the allies that the delivery of
gold at a rate of 35 dollars per u.s per
ounce of gold if you were to tender your
u.s dollar
so post bread and woods u.s becomes the
center of international finance this is
this arrangement essentially worked up
until 1967 when charles de gaulle said
time out
we want our gold here's your us dollar
and gold bars were flying back to paris
the speculators took notice of this and
there was an onslaught on the us dollar
so what did nixon do well he closed the
gold window on august 15 1971
at the same time us found itself in a
major oil predicament it was importing
over 70 percent of the oil that it
consumed and happened to be from the
middle east
we all know about the arab oil crisis in
the early 70s so nixon had a dilemma but
he came up with a solution
kissinger henry kissinger
who i actually think has a great book
out
the world order
and he also just came out and said we
are on the verge of a new cold war
so what did they do they needed to
secure the demand for the us dollar but
also secure the supply of oil to the
united states
so
nixon sent kissinger to saudi arabia
and kissinger set up what would
eventually be known as the u.s petra
dollar
so what did they do here well
if saudi arabia would trade oil only in
u.s dollars and reinvest the surplus
profits in u.s debt securities
the u.s government return would promise
military support to keep the existing
house assad the saudi family in power
and the house assad accepted and then
kuwait agreed and eventually the other
members of opec followed suit
so u.s and saudi arabia and other
members of opec had a very strong
relationship and by 1992 because they
were pumping oil into the international
markets the russians who went from 10.6
million barrels of oil a day down to 4.5
million barrels of oil a day and saw oil
prices drop by over 75 percent
they had the big pinch and we discussed
that in the book the colder war
essentially the ussr crumbled
so but all this set the stage for the
slavic warrior to take power
now obviously i'm calling vladimir putin
the slavic warrior and it's something
important for the western media to
understand to most russians in russia he
is the slavic warrior putin was born in
1952 in leningrad that's saint
petersburg
he started from very humble roots but
his grandfather spirodan ivanovich putin
really implanted vladimir putin at a
young age with really grandiose ideas
now who was his grandfather his
grandfather was the personal chef for
lenin and then when lennon passed to
lenin's wife and then
joseph stalin liked the cooking so much
and trusted him that he became and
actually outlived joseph stalin
so imagine the stories that
the personal chef of stalin had and he
shared that with vladimir putin with
young vladimir but yet putin had a lot
of
inspiration not just from his
grandfather but his favorite movie
growing up is called the shield and the
sword that's the russian equivalent to
james bond he wanted to be a spy
he also became a world competitor at
judo
so by 1970 he enrolled into the law
department at the state university in
leningrad by 1975 he was recruited as an
agent
and he looks east german and he's his
german accent was indistinguishable from
anyone else so he was sent
essentially what putin calls and i quote
himself a specialist in human relations
we in north america call it a spy
so
when putin eventually got to saint
petersburg after the collapse of ussr
he didn't hang a photo of president
yeltsin like everyone else did in russia
if you worked in the government at the
time he put a picture of peter the great
that is very important because that's
who putin most relates to he does not
relate to the modern failed politicians
of russia he wants to pick up where
peter great left off and take russia to
a new level
so
after putin consolidates the power from
the oligarchs and takes control of the
state energy infrastructure
transportation banking media firms
and the politics within the nation putin
now has to deal with external forces
first started with the rose revolution
in 2003 in georgia and then the orange
revolution in 2004 in the ukraine what
was interesting about these revolutions
they were actually funded by western
forces from the ngos george soros openly
admits to funding ngos to bring down the
satellite states around russia
so
what happens here well
2004 yushenko wins the election and
believe it or not over six years and i
actually did some business in ukraine at
the time
the government of ukraine he worked
forward
without
problems for moscow
but what changed in 2010 yushenko's
right hand and a very important ally
julia tatumashrenshko
were at odds and she wanted to become
president so what happened
moscow friendly president
yanukovych split the vote of the
pro-western side and he became
president
so
now he pledged to play
eu off of russia he was trying to get
the best deal for russia and he played
both of them off one another
unfortunately that came to backfire on
him
by late 2013 the tensions building
between pro-western and pro-russian
camps led to the orange crush as i call
it or the maiden revolution because the
city square there is called maidan
and the battle erupted and unfortunately
resulted in over four thousand people
who have died to date because of this
eventually hundreds of thousands of
people marched in protest
and as i stated unfortunately
it turned deadly
the acting president yanukovych fled to
russia and an interim government
appointed an interim president and
eventually petroshenko was elected
now let's get to the details of putin's
plans why is ukraine important to
to putin's russia there's four key
pillars to this number one pipeline half
of the natural gas that russia exports
to europe goes through ukraine they want
to bypass that by using the south stream
that's why crimea is so important
number two deep sea offshore oil and
natural gas deposits that they want to
develop in the future
number three a deep sea warm port for
the russian navy but here's one the
media is not talking about which is the
fourth very important if ukraine joins
the eu
they have an advantage by bringing in
importing goods without tariffs now that
will eat into the russian market because
the russian market has contracts with
the existing cis states as ukraine does
and now the russian manufactured goods
will have competition at a lower price
from the european goods so it's about
putin also protecting his domestic
economy so let's get into the
putinization of oil it's a word i
invented because
people like
catchy phrases like that but essentially
if you really want to know where the
fundamental basis please visit the
website colderwar.com we've got many
videos that we've created about the
putinization of not just oil natural gas
and uranium and other resources
so
in the book i break it down in great
detail the types of categories of oil
you got heavy oil you got light oil you
got sweet you got sour the different
densities
for today's talk i'm just going to clump
it all together as oil
so putin understands resources and his
strategic importance to russia's
foundation to a promising future
in 1997 he wrote his phd thesis on
exactly this topic
let's put russia as a country into
perspective i'm canadian
russia is over two times the size of
canada and canada is the second largest
landmass nation in the world
russia is probably at the top of the
world if not number two
per square kilometer of resource
endowment it's not just oil it's natural
gas it's uranium it's copper it's iron
or it's zinc
they're they're very wealthy when it
comes to resources
under putin's rain russian oil
production has increased from six
million barrels of oil per day to over
10 million barrels of crude oil per day
that is not easy to do in today's world
most importantly what's interesting 2014
a lot of media approached me and say
yeah but russia is a dying society
actually that's not true 2014 is the
first year since 1992 that the russian
birth rate is exceeding its death rate
and interestingly enough the the russian
poverty level has declined under putin
its unemployment has declined under
putin
they've doubled their gold holdings
and they have much less debt than the
western world so let's look into this
russia has anywhere between five to ten
percent of the world's proven
conventional oil resources now there's a
difference between conventional and
unconventional the success that we've
experienced here in north america is
unconventional it's taking a drill rig
vertical going horizontal and fracking
it
all unconventional is in very simple
terms is it's the source rock for the
conventional deposits
the russians haven't even started their
unconventional developments
very close friend of mine runs the
largest service company in russia and he
says man it's not even funny how much
resources they have they haven't even
started they're still producing what we
call the cheap oil or the easy oil north
america is now going for unconventional
because the cheap oil is gone
so where does this all take us arctic
oil is very important important to
putin's grand plan hence you'll see the
navy why you've seen an increase in the
navy exposure in the arctic and as
canadians we're so worried and believe
it or not where the canadian military
spends so much time is in the arctic
it's all about resources
you want to understand politics follow
the money
but more startling are the countries in
europe that depend on russian oil
finland and hungary over 75 percent of
what they consume comes from russia
czech and belgium over 50 percent
germany 40 netherlands just under 40
percent in fact in the last decade
germany increased its dependence on
former soviet oil by 52 percent
putinization of oil is based on two
strategies of putin venture outside the
continent for oil make deals with the
international markets and most
importantly drill within their own
borders especially the arctic
so
we all know now that putin succeeded
controlling the domestic supply but who
controls russia's oil sector that's
rosneft rosneff took over that little
shell company that somehow got all the
assets of yukos who controls rosneft
igor sechen he's very loyal he's been in
putin's inner circle for the past 20
years
so now what about opec and russia
russia will not join opec
opec has invited russia
russia has politely declined but russia
when convenient and beneficial to russia
will cooperate with opec
but what does this all mean in the last
35 years opec has cut production 11
times during my lifetime
and on average it reduces production by
about 1.25 million barrels per reduction
the last time that opec cup production
was in 2009
opec invited russia to the meetings
russia went to the meetings
opec shared with russia what they wanted
to do and opec decided that they were
going to cut production making the
assumption that russia agreed with opec
to cut production what did russia do
they increased production they profited
from the situation they expanded the
market share
opec lost russia won
now
today on november 27th opec's meeting
again and it's not just russia that
opecs at war with it's also the u.s
shale sector the u.s shale sector has
now become a swing producer in the
international markets so we're going to
discuss why that's important in a bit
now what about the putinization of gas
if you thought russia had it made when
it came to oil
it is a dream come true when it comes to
natural gas a lot of people in the west
don't know that russia has 25
of all the conventional natural gas in
the world remember that's not including
the unconventional
so when you look at it
as much as you know the us right now
produce about 62 billion cubic feet per
day
russia that's using conventional and
unconventional russia's just producing
from the conventional fields in siberia
about 65 billion cubic feet per day
gas prompt controls almost all of the
russian natural gas who controls gas
prom well you better believe it alexa
miller before him dimitri medvedev these
are all inner circle allies and loyalist
putin
so what does this all mean
in europe germany depends on 40 percent
of the
natural gas they consume comes from
russia poland 87
finland 100
even the uk 25
now all this happened was the largest
successful uh shale gas formation
was from a company called quadrilla
which i was the largest shareholder
initially in in the finance here in the
first two rounds the bowling shales in
the uk
proved up a little over 100 tcf's that's
a hundred trillion cubic feet of gas and
yet that's enough gas to supply britain
for about 200 years
but they still depend on 25 of their gas
from russia
lord brown who used to run bp who really
understands the issues with russia
because of bp's investment in tnk
well he's the chairman of cuadrilla so
he understands what's going on
but now everything's changed the largest
construction project in the world's not
in north america it's not in europe it's
the natural gas pipeline from russia to
china
eventually we will see what this all
means
but russia by 2028 will be exporting
more natural gas just to china than all
of europe combined more importantly when
you build a major pipeline like that you
can twin it and then you can start
shipping out arteries to other markets
that will happen and what about lng
liquify natural gas everybody here in
north america is talking about the lng
revolution well unfortunately the us and
canada are at least five years behind
russia and qatar
and australia in that matter
and when you look at the giant fields
that the russians have
you look at the stockholm giant gas
field which has
you know equivalent to a billion barrels
of oil
they're already building these things
more importantly there's something
called flng i don't know if anyone's
heard of this it's floating lng the
russians have already started building
two these are the biggest ships on the
planet and you can move into the arctic
where there's no infrastructure and the
ship is essentially a floating lng
sector there's one in operation right
now of the northern coast of australia
and now let's talk about the
putinization of uranium
america is the largest consumer of
uranium in the world anywhere between 45
to 50 million pounds annually for the
last 20 years
on average about 20 percent of america's
electricity is generated via nuclear
energy
half of that
nuclear energy the uranium came from
russia
that means that 10 percent of america's
electricity generated over the last
decade came from russia that's one in
every 10 homes in america
globally 71 plants are under
construction
163 are planned and 325 25 nuclear
reactors are proposed
all of this is in the emerging markets
almost half
of the current primary uranium
production on the planet is within
russia's control
interestingly enough if you take
all of the uranium production in 2013 in
america one russian company produced
more uranium on american soil than all
the american companies combined
scary thought half of the world's
uranium resources are within the russian
sphere of influence
and most importantly almost half of the
world's enrichment capacity of uranium
is within russia's control
all of the growth of the nuclear sector
is in the emerging markets that is where
putin is focusing his future on
so what does this all mean we bring this
all together and we see a judgment day
for the petrodollar
opec
and most of the worlds by the early 70s
have been using the petro dollar
however if putin is successful in his
plan it would involve the demise of the
petrodollar we have an amazing video on
this on our website colderwar.com
major major oil and natural gas deals
are occurring in non-us dollars around
the world we've seen the most recent one
with
russia and iran russia is going to build
eight nuclear reactors provide a life of
supply of uranium and operate the
facilities non-us dollars a 400 billion
dollar natural gas deal in non-us
dollars
but will opec turn their back on the us
dollar that is the key critical question
here u.s
was saudi arabia's largest
customer for crude oil that has all
changed
part of the oil war is now opecs at war
with the u.s shale sector why because of
the success of the north american shale
sector u.s now are exporting ngls and
condensates there's a ban right now in
america that you can't export crude oil
but there's no ban on refined products
what does that mean
u.s shale providers
producers are now competing with saudi
arabia and qatar and kuwait in the
international markets in the ngls and
condensate markets
that's not good for saudi arabia their
number one customer is now china and
usually
a producer goes with what its customer
wants
so what does this all mean
the success of the us domestic energy
has increased
output and production therefore the
import of energy from the middle east
has become less important to america's
foreign policy
but what a lot of people in the media
and most americans don't know is
actually the us military presence in the
middle east that has been subsidizing
the european energy supply that comes
from mena middle east and north africa
this is now significantly at risk
in the last four years we've seen the
arab spring a change in many governments
in the middle east and a power vacuum
that continues
with the us military leaving and
unfortunately for everyone isis and al
qaeda are expanding the war in iraq is
nowhere near
complete it's getting worse
expect the conflicts in ukraine to get
worse before it gets better
and as the u.s pulls out
more instability and volatility
in the middle east will increase
what about the shaky house assad let's
talk about saudi arabia it's the world's
number two oil producer after russia
and it's at great risk
you look at
the king right now is over 90 years old
his successor his brother is in his late
70s and
late 70s is not doing well health-wise
there are seven thousand princes who are
vying to become the next king in line
that's not good more importantly let's
look at the demographics of saudi arabia
it's a majority sunai sunni country
but
all of the oil production comes from the
east coast everyone's heard of the
gowahar oil field it's the largest oil
field producer in the world
unfortunately the majority unfortunately
for the existing saudi arabia regime the
majority of the people within the oil
producing region where all of the oil
production in saudi arabia comes from
are shiites there's over 50 unemployment
of adult males in this region and it's
just a ticking time bomb ready to go one
guaranteed result of any war in a
producing region you know that we don't
know who will win we don't know what's
going to happen but one guarantee is oil
production decreases another thing that
is very very important that people don't
talk about
that could change overnight is
the seven global choke points of oil for
example the hor the strait of hormuz
which is right where bahrain is and just
further south about one third of all the
world's oil travels through that little
straight another street that no one
talks about is the strait of malacca
that's the oil that goes to asia hence
what is the south china sea bubble
that's about to pop all about these are
major issues that are going on globally
so what has russia done under putin's
leadership well it's actually expanded
its relationships and production via
ross prom
rosneft and gas prom
in middle east and north africa
for example israel
believe it or not i spent a lot of time
there and most people are shocked when i
say they have world class natural gas
potential israel has the potential to
become a world lng exporter
guess who's all over it not the us
companies gas prom
europe depends on russia for energy and
putin has executed on finalizing new
market for russian energy
which is in china and the rest of asia
all this leads us towards the twilight
of the petro dollar
what happens if the u.s petrodollar
falls well first of all the cost to
finance u.s government debt will be
higher as the u.s currency depreciates
and debt will cost higher and interest
rates will result thus the average
american's debt cost will be more
expensive to service remember today's
debt is greater than 100 percent of the
gdp thus the standard of living for the
middle class and poor will decline much
further
but that is the best case scenario it
can get a lot worse
as derivative markets could become
significant victims of the demise of the
petrodollar
there are over 500 trillion dollars in
derivatives market that's the
conservative estimate a lot of people
have published books that it's well over
a quadrillion dollars i don't even know
how big that number is and i used to
teach calculus so quadrillion is a big
big number
so what happens to the derivative
markets
which by the way warren buffett called
weapons of mass destruction if the
petrodollar
collapses well it will increase major
volatility and instability in the
markets
is this possible yes
we already see many nations setting up
currency swaps worth trillions of
dollars in non-us dollar denominations
all taking demand away from the us
dollar in fact a lot of people again 70
percent of all the hand-to-hand currency
that's a hundred dollar bills the 20
bills are actually held by foreign
foreign foreigners 70 percent of the 100
bills and all the currency are held by
foreigners outside of the us there's
actually more 100 u.s bills in russia
than there is in america
interestingly enough one-third of all
the u.s bank checking deposits in the
u.s which works out to be a about a
little over a trillion dollars in u.s
dollars are owned by foreigners
if there is a currency collapse based
upon the fall of the petro dollar you
will expect that these foreigners will
dump these dollars and will cause
further pressure on the u.s dollar
so what has the us government done to
prevent this well
in 2013
the u.s government made up about
one-third of the total military
expenditures globally but a little over
640 billion dollars remember the little
facts i gave you earlier in the 19th
century in the 20th century and the 21st
century the u.s are involved in every
major global conflict that usually
doesn't work too well for a country
if you believe in trends of the past so
what is the best case scenario if the
u.s policy doesn't change stagflation
high unemployment negative economic
growth and rapid price inflation
the biggest loser in this scenario will
be the middle class
you'll basically become you'll go from
working middle class comfortable to the
working poor especially the baby boomers
who plan on living on fixed incomes
the worst case
u.s or the eu or japan
default
on the debt held by the foreigners
this single event would be the most
interesting day ever in the history of
the financial markets
and we will all be victims of it
so how can you protect yourself from
this it's not something that just the
rich or hedge fund managers can do we
can all do it
first off limit your debt and attempt to
become debt free simple basic rules
to protect yourself from the demise of
the petrodollar buy a little bit of
physical gold as an insurance in case
the us dollar does crash
and you hope that gold you never
actually use it because
if gold does go to five or ten thousand
dollars per ounce
the world's going to be in a very bad
place
diversify your holdings internationally
hopefully for the younger people in the
audience don't just have one passport
don't just have one bank account have
two passports
try to have internationalize your assets
and most importantly we can all profit
from the colder war by investing in
companies run by the right management
teams who understand how to bring the
right to modern technology to pass
producing oil fields or gas fields or
uranium fields you can profit from this
you look at what's going to happen in
mexico mexico is going to become a game
changer
unfortunately for mexico they've been
using the profits from the oil sector to
fund social programs the great cantorell
field in mexico has gone from over 3
million barrels a day of production to
just above 600 000 major declines
you look at exxon america's largest oil
company their largest netbacks that's
how much you make per production a
barrel of oil
isn't in the gulf of mexico it's not in
the middle east
it's actually in germany
so yet these fields have never seen
modern technology so invest in what the
countries need to do to diversify from
the russian supply of energy we are in a
cold war it's going to take many many
years to play out but protect yourself
is your responsibility
thank you very much
so i'm here to take any questions i'm
here
ask away yes sir
thank you
sure
great how do you see the impact of
international efforts on
bringing of controlling global warming
on the uh the effects on the uh
hydrocarbon fuel markets both gas and
oil and will it change this overall
picture of gloom that you're giving us
unfortunately it won't let's take
germany for example that is trying to be
the the world leader in green energy uh
for the last five years year over year
the electricity costs in germany have
increased 25 percent to the point that
it's not economic without government
subsidies and as a result
uh the manufacturing in germany's
leaving germany and yet they've
increased their dependence on former
soviet oil by 52 over the last decade so
you know you look at the numbers
we're about a hundred years away from it
it's great political lip service for the
politicians to have these grand ideas
and talk about all these fabulous ideas
but you know we're years away from you
know the the enemy of solar being just
night
i finance the largest geothermal plant
built in the u.s in the last 25 years
it's very difficult to make it economic
so
hydrocarbons are here to say what i will
say though i just got back from china
and the airpocalypse that's occurring
there with the highest asthma rates in
the world
china definitely has to get away from
their coal remember they consume about
70 percent of the globus coal
consumption and i think they're going to
definitely make a big push for nuclear
energy which is
the cleanest form of energy
base load energy and the problem with
green energy is it's not base load solar
wind they're not dependable they're not
base load power like coal natural gas or
uranium
yes sir in the back
thank you very much for your uh your
insight and your commentary i i have to
ask about the your opinion of the the
simultaneous decline of the ruble
the russian stock market
and obviously price of oil um seeing
brent back down to you know mid 70s how
long can
russia continue to exert influence
um with prices at those levels coming
down from you know the mid one teens
sure
so we actually discussed this in the
book the colder war because part of the
cycle is you know before the great
inflation you're going to have deflation
and
the key here for people to understand
saudi arabia russia
to balance their budgets to keep all
their social programs happy you know
they balance between 90 to 105 oil but
the russian oil can be economic at 40
and make a good return they just have to
adjust their budgets
their social budgets more importantly
the ruble has devalued much more than
the price of oil
therefore that's an advantage to the
russian oil producers because they
actually make more money because they're
selling in
a depreciating currency so that's an
advantage
the side effects of the sanctions
against russia which were hoping to
crumble their economy has actually
pushed them closer to china and that the
chinese will make huge deals moving
forward with the russians this is just
the beginning of what we've seen
the chinese don't care what obama or
america or germany think on sanctions
their china the chinese government's
about securing their 50-year business
plan moving forward a secure stable
supply of energy
yes sir
um i believe we're the biggest oil
producer aren't we no so we're going to
be fairly soon
well the question there will be
will the u.s shale sector
be able to still grow and fight the
declines the problem with the
unconventional sector is after your
first year of production you have
anywhere between 50 to 75 percent
declines per well
what
the media here is saying we're going to
be
we're almost energy independent
that report came out from iea it was a
380 page report and the report never
said by 2028 america will become energy
independent it said if all of these 12
assumptions happen we'll almost become
energy independent so at 50 oil will
america continue its growth in
production no can a lot of the
production in the u.s sustain itself at
65 75 oil yes but what you're talking
about is combining the
barrels of oil equivalent with the
natural gas and the oil
actually but also with one quick
question too is
if things are going so bad and the
petrol dollars is coming to an end why
is the dollar rising in the market
there's nowhere else
what will replace it there's nothing out
there to do with it eventually chinese
won't float unless the chinese called
the wine well they have to stabilize
their future first so that's exactly you
know there's an old joke about the u.s
dollar it's the tallest [ __ ] in a room
of midgets and the problem is is unless
the u.s foreign policy changes and
accepts china and russia's equals rather
than you know telling them what to do
and implementing sanctions which is the
worst thing you're going to see the rest
of the world move away now where would
you rather go the euro the yen they're
even more screwed up than the us dollar
but until the new brick bank establishes
itself we're talking a few years out
there will be alternatives where you
know the debt for example for every
dollar of debt that a government would
take in the 50s the us government would
see 4.6 times growth in the gdp
today for every dollar of debt you take
you see eight cents
on the dollar of growth so the financial
heroin is not working we've seen the
most recent one japan even though
they've
basically injected a trillion yen into
the economy they still announced uh
yesterday that they're in a recession so
in the near term yes the russian doll
the us dollar is the strongest currency
but let's look at the last decade or the
last century it was britain and things
change and unless america changes their
approach it's going to change sooner
than later
thank you for uh again for your comments
and for the book um so you said america
has to change its approach do you
provide some kind of recommendation or
can you talk about that a little bit i
think what needs to happen is the next
president of the u.s
let's take what happened in syria where
you know the u.s funded the rebels to
fight assad
regime
and people forget that putin took out a
full-page newspaper in the new york
times saying this is foolish why are you
funding the exact people that you're at
war with
and that today it has become true
the u.s and canada and its allies are
bombing isis which were originally
funded and using military equipment
provided by the us in iraq today
unfortunately isis is getting stronger
and now they've joined forces with
al-qaeda there's no secrets that saudi
arabia has also been funding them so
what happens here well until
europe
and america and the allies to the west
the emerge
respect and recognize that russia has
their interests china has their
interests and you have to work as equals
to create a modern solution
it's not russia that's been expanding
its military if you actually look back
over the 20 years
nato has actually grown in membership
nato has been expanding its own agendas
so you look at what happened in kosovo
and i spent a lot of time in kosovo
where you set up one of the largest
companies and resources there and the
first ones and you get a real
perspective of what's going on even the
us sanctions today are not legal
according to the laws of the un security
council so there needs to be more
dialogue and there's a major
miscommunication going on globally
that's where it has to start
do you feel like there is any um leader
that's present or you know that's a
leader now or someone emerging that gets
it and you feel like
you know is taking the right approach
well what was interesting
what was interesting and you know i'm a
political i i look at just from an
investment perspective where i can make
money from this current situation the
current realities
i remember in the election in 2012 when
mitt romney said our biggest enemy is
america's biggest enemy is russia and
obama laughed on it laughed at him in re
and said
the cold war is over
well within a year of that that comment
you know it was russia that stood up
to
america with the red line comment and
the rest of the world's taking notice
now when the ussr crumbled no one
expected putin to rise from the ashes
and do what he's done
so do i see anyone right now no but
let's all hope that there is someone
there i just don't have the answer for
that
thank you for this presentation
i i was reading in the financial times
that
for russia as a budget to
to be a goal that the crude oil has to
be 110 dollars per barrel it was a very
graphic image and it showed the
break-even point for kuwait and for the
other countries
and um
i also wanted to to to i don't know add
to what you're saying i think there are
two two american companies that are
already giving approval by congress to
be able to export uh us three three now
yes it was eog
and um
excuse me the the third thing is if this
uh uh china and russia if they are so
confident that the
there will be a demise or a death in the
us dollar in the future that's why in 50
or 60 years if they are so confident and
they are extrapolating so much into the
future and they are making so many grand
use plans and and securing their
resources elsewhere for different
commodities why are they not holding
their own currency why isn't the chinese
so confident why are they holding a
majority of their
foreign reserves in the usd sure and as
well as as the other
so i'll start with the first one the
first one was you know for new projects
in russia
kuwait you mentioned the other members
of opec that article what media stating
is for the countries to balance their
budgets that's very different than
making an economic return on your oil so
russia is a bit different than say
kuwait which i spent time in kuwait and
really there is no middle class in
kuwait you got your imported
let's call it non-slave workers but
essentially you know they're glorified
slaves and then you have the royal
family that's very different than let's
say russia or some of the other
countries like mexico where the state
oil companies you can actually
like rosneft is a publicly traded
company
but the taxes are used to fund
the the social programs of the
government
exactly
and the other thing is if the russia is
not break-even for their
if russia this is because if if you
cannot balance your budget because the
primary commodity you use to feed your
government is going down the the price
in the general market because it's
commodity there's nothing special that's
different what you're referring to is
something called the dutch disease and
the dutch
the dutch disease is based off of when
you have a strong currency and you're
producing and then the price of that
commodity crashes you're stuck because
it's you have price inflation
domestically yes but what's very
different in russia their currency was
overvalued because of oil and like i
stated earlier their currency is
depreciated at a greater rate than oil
so russia and companies are actually
better off so it's the opposite of dutch
disease yeah the dodge did this the way
i read it maybe because i'm not so smart
my iq is so maybe the way i read it was
that in dodgy disease you your
government depend on one commodity price
the same thing going all over you know
many you know
you look african venezuela
nigeria but russia is very different on
this yeah
i'm not trying i'm not i'm just learning
so much from you on you i got wrote
three pages and my brain is
so if you cannot don't need to write
there's a book
if you cannot balance your budget yeah
but let's talk about the budget russia
has over 450 million dollars in reserve
currency they've over tripled their gold
reserves under putin's administration
the chinese have over doubled you know
the largest gold producer in the world
is it's not america it's not nevada it's
actually china
china is the largest importer of oil so
oh gold is money
no no no don't fool yourself
gold is money did you have a question
yes um with the decline of the us
influence on the global energy market do
you see something like the manhattan
project
developing
to replace certain forms of energy well
it was interesting we talked about that
in the book because
the to replace to do what the manhattan
project was today
in today's dollars would be over a
trillion dollar investment from the
government and it really revolutionized
what became nuclear energy
obama tried that with the green
revolution you know the guaranteed
construction loans for the companies and
it was a disaster it was a disaster in
the tens of billions of dollars so no i
don't see that being a solution
unfortunately
yes sir
this has been fascinating uh just a
couple points i want to clarification on
things you said earlier
uh looking at israel's fine for a moment
i was in the impression that we're
american companies you said it was rose
enough that's chasing i thought noble
energy yeah so mobile energy is one of
them in the leviathan basin and the
offshore i actually went to the platform
but if you look at the cost to actually
build this infrastructure the energy
noble can't afford it so you know for
example during obama's first term he
never visited israel putin and medvedev
were there five or six times so you see
that when the collapse of russia ussr
happened in 92 over 300 000 russian
jewish engineers went to israel
and and really the influence there and
they stick with their governments they
had money they're very smart educated
successful so gasprom has its eyes
definitely on israel let's take iraq
when i went to iraq we all know the
military of the u.s were there in the
2000s took down saddam interestingly
enough saddam wanted to trade uh oil for
euros not us dollars he went down after
the new regime came in there was no
mention of trading oil and nothing other
than u.s dollars but more importantly
who's doing all the service contracts in
iraq it's the chinese it's the russians
it's not the north american companies
that are drilling the projects you go to
africa in the east african rift
the largest onshore oil discovery in the
plan in the last decade is a company
called africa oil i was involved in that
company and they've proved up now over a
billion barrels of oil who's doing all
the work it's chinese drill rigs so
unfortunately
the north american companies did not win
the contracts because exxon for example
in iraq they're already working in iraq
and when the kurdish oil fields open the
iraq government said if you go to
kurdistan which we won't recognize you
lose your contracts in iraq
so the foreigners came in
good i just want to follow up the other
part of the middle east you talked about
is iran and russia supplying them and
possibly being the solution on the
nuclear front i hope so so it would be
nice to have a real solution to all this
chaos so i just i wanted you to expand
on that yeah so what happened was after
the first uh the natural gas deal with
russia and china before putin went back
to russia he hopped over to iran and
they started their negotiations for
nuclear
power pact
and this past week it was signed that
iran has agreed to have the russians
fund build supply the uranium and
operate for over 25 years eight nuclear
reactors in iran
yes sir
uh just a point of clarification i
returned in march from 10 years in
baghdad
so i just like to clarify one thing
about the oil sector in
in iraq as with many other countries
subsoil resources belong to the country
not to the region that happens or the
person who happens to be parked on the
surface
so those oil fields that are in the
kurdish region of iraq belong to the
country not to the kurds
and the law is quite clear about that
the constitution calls for it as a
matter of fact
so those companies like exxon mobil who
had advisers who encouraged the laws
that's right i encourage them to go make
a deal with the kurds because it's quick
money and you'll get it out through
through turkey we're very ill advised
because how could the iraqi government
rely over 95 percent on oil revenues for
everything more importantly look at the
kirkuk field of fantastic oil fields uh
janelle energy has been producing 25 40
000 barrels a day oil fields but there's
three main pipelines in northern
kurdistan and how are they going to get
the oil out when you have three they're
trucking the oil out there's a lot of
problems in
four years ago i wrote a report when i
got back from iraq saying i'm not
putting my dollars there there's just
too much chaos and i wrote the article
called the edge of chaos based on it
well the the point of all this isn't
that it is to say that some countries do
not have diversified economies and rely
too much on
you know the country that's grown the
best out of that mess is mexico
venezuela has not saudi arabia has not
none of the other major oil producers
even mexico pemex is changing their
rules because it it even hasn't been
successful so anyway
just a point a counterpoint to your
analysis is rather than looking just at
what the oil sector is doing in the and
the country and its budget one has to
look at the diversity of the economy to
see whether there's resiliency there
that can move from one sector to another
as our scan for example yep and that's
where we talk in the book where like i
mentioned putin's foundation to his
future plan is the resource sector but
you can't depend on it and that's what
we kind of explained in the book
thank you very much well thank you very
much
[Applause]
okay so uh to have time for uh books and
signing uh et cetera we'll we're
wrapping up the questions obviously now
and uh thank you all very much for
coming and look forward to seeing you
next time
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book tv
send us an email to booktv cspan.org
tweet us book tv or post on our wall
facebook.com